this all-covered boat lying idly on
polluted Waters mirror the lives of
people here in Nigeria's ogoni region
they've waited three decades for their
damaged land vegetation and water to be
cleaned up
four years ago following public pressure
and criticism Royal Dutch Shell and the
Nigerian government began clearing up
some of the 65 sites identified in a
United Nations environment report
a billion dollars was set aside for the
work
to date we have done 50 Lots comprising
of 20 sites
from the unit report so we have about 45
sites left to to handle and these 45
sites have been classified as the
semi-complex to complex sides
here new Mangrove shoots have sprouted
an aquatic life is slowly coming back
signs that the cleanup could reverse the
devastation
the United Nations environment report of
2011 says even with serious commitment
it could take up to 50 years to restore
the environment to what it used to be
environmentally say the way the work has
been planned and conducted is wrong by
now we expect that beyond your side
mediation there should be elimination of
groundwater there should be Shoreline
remediation this has not been done
officials say more extensive clearance
will begin soon
although six water projects are about to
be completed most people living here are
still exposed to dangerous levels of oil
pollution
the amount of carcinogenic Benzene in
the underground water here is 900 times
more than what the World Health
Organization considers safe for humans
yet people live around this site some
even drink the water use it for washing
and that led to some severe health
problems and even dying
the United Nations calls the agony
cleanup one of the most ambitious
environmental restoration projects ever
attempted while all this is going on
more oil is being spilled in the Niger
Delta something activists say could
reverse the small gains met here so far